[Music]
Christian
good
evening
hi ah thanks I love audience
participation thank you for being here
tonight at the table my name is Karen
Miner I'm part of the leadership team
and a warm extra warm welcome especially
on a cold night like tonight extra warm
welcome to all of you especially our
guests that are with us tonight uh I
hope you feel welcomed and at home here
uh and clearly you're here on a very
special evening yay we don't always have
a a trough full of water here um but we
have baptisms happening tonight and I
can't wait wait it's always such a
special uh event here at the table and a
great way to kick off the year um I have
a couple of announcements um make sure
you're tuning into these they are they
are important um and I have visual aids
because they're so important uh ah the
first one is we have a workshop that is
coming up uh this coming Thursday
evening right here in this room from 7
to 900 p.m. if you are interested in
growing as an ally of the lgbtq
community if you just want to grow in
your awareness and education this is a
great Workshop to attend uh the table is
sponsoring it so it's free to you to
attend but you do need to register um
it's going to be facilitated by one of
our table friends her name is Peppa she
is a presbyterian Minister speaker
writer presenter she's amazing amazing I
saw her present a while back and I was
just writing down just about everything
she said she is wonderful and so
knowledgeable so if you were interested
in attending uh you can scan the QR code
that's behind me we also have these
flyers that will be out uh as you go out
the back door here on your right there's
a table you can grab a flyer and you can
scan the QR code or there's also a link
to sign up on our website at the
tx.org
secondly big new news that I hope most
of you have heard already but if you
haven't we have outgrown our beloved
Pleasant Valley United Methodist Church
which makes us sad um but there's really
nowhere else for us to grow here and so
we're going to be changing
locations uh starting on the first
Sunday of the month February 4th we're
going to be meeting at First United
Methodist in saxi so we're not going
very far just maybe 5 10 minutes down
the road and to help you out we have
Maps thanks to Marissa back there in the
tech Booth who has colorcoded them for
your convenience and Clarity like super
impressive so we have tonight and then
next Sunday and then the Sunday after
that is when we're going to be meeting
at First United Methodist saxi 5:00 p.m.
so same same service time make sure when
you head out pick up one of these
there's a stack of them on your way out
and also if you scan the QR code you can
also see that address on our link tree
so that's available for you as well just
to make sure you get to the right place
but there's a lot more parking a lot
more space for our kids um so while we
just are really sad to leave Pleasant
Valley we'll still stay connected to
them but we'll have some more room and
room to grow uh at first saxi so I hope
you'll join us for that all right those
are my announcements and visual aids um
let's take a moment to just quiet
ourselves take a
breath close your eyes if you're
comfortable doing
so let's just quiet quiet our
minds take a deep breath if that's
helpful for
you just be still for a
moment be present here
now set aside the day thus
far think about why you're here or why
you want to be
here and pray with
me God thank you for tonight thank you
for each person here each person tuning
in online
God I pray your blessings over each
one God that your presence would be felt
tangibly by each one of us God we would
feel your love through the music tonight
the
baptisms stories that are shared the
people around us God help us to remember
we're not
alone and that we can Center on you on
your faith fness your
goodness the plans you have for
us that we can trust in
you give us Faith to do that give us
hope help us to Center on you
God in Jesus name I pray
amen all right we're doing a
quick there it is quick check there my
instrument wasn't there for during Ken
PR so I want to make sure welcome and
thank you guys for joining us um we
are few but we are strong
tonight we lost um Mindy who typically
leads the worship on Sunday nights is
home sick with the flu and so she
normally plays percussion and leads our
vocals and stuff so we're just going to
ask you guys to just join in louder than
ever feel free to clap and sing and um
join in however you will but would you
just start by standing with us and we're
going to go ahead and sing this first
song all together while our kiddos are
still with us in the room and um and
then we'll dismiss them and move
[Music]
forward can sing this with me
this is a call to all the dead and
disappointed the ones who feel like they
are
done this is a word to all the ones who
feel forgotten that you are
not you are
not cuz we're alive alive alive and
we're singing we're alive alive alive
and we're shaking we're alive alive
alive alive in
[Music]
you we are soaked in all the grace that
we've been given Unchained from all that
we have
done your Mercy's Rising like the sun on
the horizon
and we're coming
home coming
home we're alive alive alive and we're
singing we're alive alive alive and
we're shaking we're alive alive alive
alive in
you we're
alive we're alive alive alive and we're
singing we're alive alive alive and
we're shaken we're alive alive alive
alive in
you Lord if you can fill us Lord if you
can use us fill us up let us feel your
love wash over us Lord if you can use us
fill
us let us feel your love rush over sing
that Lord Lord if you can use us
us let us feel your love rush over us
Lord if you can use us fill us up let us
feel your love rush over
[Music]
us we're alive alive alive and we're
singing we're alive alive alive and
we're shaken we're alive alive alive
alive in
you sing that again we're alive we're
alive alive alive and we're singing
we're alive alive alive and we're
shaking we're alive alive alive alive in
[Music]
you all right thank you guys kiddos you
can be dismissed to your classes we've
got first grade and down on this right
side of the room over here with our
Preschool teachers and then second grade
and up are over here and um if you guys
would stay standing we're g to go ahead
and sing this next
[Music]
song
heart every C
[Music]
stand I believe that you are my
foress oh you are my
por you are my Hiding
Place I believe you are the
way the
truth the
life I believe you are the
way
the
truth the
life I believe through every
blessing through every
promise through every breath I
take I believe that you are
provider oh you are
protector you are the one I love oh I
believe you are
the
way the
truth the
life I believe you are the
way the
truth the
life I believe you
[Music]
are
it's a New
Horizon and I'm set on you and you made
me here today with mercies that
new all my fears and
doubts they can all come to because they
can't stay long when I'm here with
you it's a New
Horizon and I'm set on you you meet me
here today with mercies that
I all my fears and doubts they can all
come to because they can't stay long
when I believe you are the
[Music]
way the
truth the
life I believe you are the
way the truth
the
life I believe you are the
way the
truth the
life I believe you are no
way the
truth the
life I believe you are it's a new AR
and I'm set on
you and you meet me here to with mercies
that are
new and all my fears and
doubts they can all come
to because they can't stay long when I'm
here with
you
[Music]
hi we at this moment in time do
something called prayers of the people
it's one of my favorite things and it
praise over everyone you could possibly
imagine and I love that so if you would
online you guys can there's a moment
where you guys can type a little comment
about somebody you want to pray for
we'll take a break in the end you'll see
you can read but follow along with me as
I read
all
right okay for the city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and will to conserve it we pray
to you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
dusted itute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to
you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you for the name and moments we have
spoken aloud and for those we have kept
in our hearts we pray to you that they
might have light life healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
you
leing we're gonna sing this next song
and it's one that has
been um something that I come back to
over and over and over again again
because as much as probably each one of
us could stand in front of the room and
talk about different ways that maybe
people have let us down maybe the church
has even let you down at times or failed
you there is this one constant through
my life that God has been there for me
to return to regardless of what season
I'm walking through and no matter how
far I get from the people that I love or
even myself at times times I can come
back to him and feel like oh my gosh
you're still there you didn't change
you're still consistent and that's what
this song speaks about and um I hope
that it can be sung from a place of
authenticity for each of us as we just
reflect on a God who is
faithful I Love You
Lord oh your mercies never fail me
all my days I've been held in your
hands from the moment that I wake
up until I lay my
head I will sing of the
goodness of
God all my
life all my life you have been faithful
and all my life you have been so so
good with every breath that I
able I will sing of the
goodness of
God I love your
voice you have me through the
in night you are close like
other I've known you as a
father I've known you as a
friend I have Liv in the goodness of
God all my life you have been
[Music]
you
have so
good with every breath that
I I will sing of the goodness of
God I will sing of the
goodness of God
your goodness is running after it's
running your goodness is running after
it's running after me with my life laid
down I Surrender now and give you
everything goodness is running after
it's running after
me it's running after
[Music]
me
have oh my life you have been so so
good with every breath that I
am I will sing of the
goodness of
[Music]
God I will sing of the
goodness of
God
yes
God Jesus you are our
story you are my
song and the one Dependable
source of healing hope life
forgiveness towards ourselves and others
God we receive that right
now and we thank you for your faith
fness and we reenter on
you remembering the
times that we hit rock bottom only to
find that you are the rock that does not
move that does not
change so God for all of our failings
and all of the failings of others around
us God we offer forgiveness and Grace
and we receive the
gift that you have offered
tonight God would you be at the center
of our worship and the center of our
praise in the center of this
service in your name that we pray
amen thank you guys as you're seated
would you just say hello to the people
around you and um take a moment to greet
them and help everyone feel welcome and
at
home
go well Grace and peace it is so good to
be with you all uh my name is Brett and
um yeah I'm just I'm grateful grateful
to be with you and uh to welcome all of
you but as always always that includes
those joining us online love y'all lots
and um anyone here tonight who is new
with us and uh with baptisms that's
there's usually some folks are visiting
um and uh so yeah we're really really
glad that that you're here with us on
this it's just a special a special night
so um the title of my message on this
baptism Sunday is prophets priests
royalty and
ego and uh our passage is Hebrews chap 1
uh veres
1-3 and it says this in the past God
spoke to our ancestors through the
prophets at many times and in various
ways but in these last days he has
spoken to us by his son whom he
appointed heir of all things and through
whom also he made the universe the sun
is the radiance of God's glory and the
exact
representation of his being sustaining
All Things by his power powerful word
you can see there the writer of Hebrews
even so early in Christian history
already trying to kind of work out some
Theology of like oh my gosh who was
Jesus because you know because there was
I mean the resurrected one but like but
what does that mean you know and what
what was Jesus relationship to the one
he called father it's like oh my
goodness there they um yeah you can see
that kind of getting worked you know
worked out here uh after he had provided
purification for sins he sat down at the
right hand of the Majesty in
heaven so so one way to kind of reflect
on the life of Jesus and then through um
Christ kind of to reflect on our own
life uh as the community of the baptized
is uh through what's known as the
threefold office uh or the three-fold
identity and it's those three words that
popped up in the the title of the
message uh Prophet priest and uh
formerly it was King I also want to kind
of expand that gender-wise but also
inclusive because there's um right for
the for us as a community it's it's not
just about you know Kings but it's it's
kind of the idea of royalty or as we get
into the message you'll see um even the
idea of just leadership you know which
is kind of what the the kingly queenly
royalty role um tends to be about and uh
if you kind of go back to Hebrew Bible
um known as to Christians as the Old
Testament you kind of see these three
roles that were just so important in
society um right there was the prophet
the priest and then the kind of king or
leader and in our kind of passage from
Hebrews it's like a good little summary
I mean if you think of like the gospels
in general you could kind of think of
places where like yeah Jesus was kind of
function in the role of prophet kind of
in the role of priest even if he was
never like an official priest in that
sense of like he served in the temple
you know but but still I mean we'll get
into kind of through the cross right
he's kind of priest um and then the kind
of kingly royalty role even thinking
again of the Cross um that's a sort of
like this is where you kind of get all
these roles turned upside down and away
and kind of questioned and interrogated
because the way Jesus fulfilled them
right was so unique and
unexpected um but you can kind of think
of the Gospel you can kind of see where
Jesus fulfilled these fulfills these
roles but like about the Hebrews passage
is it's a place where it's sort of like
all encapsulated you know just like
right there you kind of have all three
so for example the prophetic role of
Christ is alluded to there in verse one
in the first part of verse two says in
the past God spoke to our ancestors
through the prophets and at uh at many
times and in various ways but in these
last days he has spoken to us by his son
right so it's the idea of Christ hears
the words hears the voice of the one he
called father and then does
what speaks them right to us and that's
basically the prophetic role to kind of
discern the voice of the spirit and then
to speak it out right so Christ of
course he he did that um and I should
say while we believe Christ was more
than a prophet um it's not as though he
was less than that or not that like no
no he he was he he was a prophet right
he fulfilled that prophetic role um and
then we can see both the kind of
Priestly and the the kind of royalty
leader nature of Jes Jesus in the second
part of verse three um it says after he
had provided purification for sins right
so that's kind of an illusion to the to
the Cross um where in that moment he's
kind of both priest and sacrifice in a
way um he continues he sat down at the
right hand of the Majesty in heaven
right that of course there's the royalty
piece um because whoever sat to the
right of the king had the power and
authority of the King right so so
there's kind of you see the the kingly
kind of nature of Christ there
um now here's the thing you might ask
what does this have to do with baptism
so glad you asked y'all are so on it uh
Anglican Theologian Rowan Williams he he
puts it really succinctly he said for
many centuries the church has thought of
Jesus as anointed by God to live out a
three-fold identity that of you guessed
it Prophet priest and King the baptized
person identifies with Jesus in these
three ways of Being Human which
characterize and Define his unique
Humanity as we grow into his life in
humanity these three ways come to
characterize us as well the life of the
baptized is a life of
Prophecy priesthood and
royalty ain't that beautiful now here's
kind of my question is um I think when
we kind of hear it put so succinctly
like in that way Rowan Williams did we
can kind of see like oh okay I could
kind of I could kind of get it you know
I could kind of see the connection and
like okay maybe I am called to this you
know but where I've been kind of
reflecting is on the question
of why well a we don't talk a lot about
this in church anymore you know like I
don't know if and I can be even honest
here at the table I don't know if I've
ever done a message on you know the
prophet priest and the King you know and
and just know never never done that and
um and I'm kind of you know been
reflecting like why
and there's something about these these
these words Prophet priest king um it's
not just the words though I mean well so
here let me kind of put it succinctly so
I think there's kind of two reasons one
we might just call it cultural
remoteness you know that we just no
longer really live like in an era of
kind of you know for example kings
queens so there's kind of some distance
there now we can even say well but you
know prophets there's especially if
you've been in kind of Pentecostal
charismatic circles like still prophets
and um you know priests pastors that's
still you know still a thing maybe the
way I'd frame it is at the very least
like these roles don't have the uh what
would be the term like the cache or
something like the the oomph that they
once did in the culture like these used
to be sort of
esteemed roles you know that people were
like
ooh you know yeah I wish I could be that
you know like king a king a queen
royalty the to operate in the role of
the prophetic oh I mean I don't know
when was the last time you were like if
only I could be like Isaiah of old a
prophet of the Lord you know I don't
know like maybe that's not as much of a
dream for people you know or the last
time you're like oh if only I could be a
priest or Pastor oh that was just my
favorite role you know I don't I mean I
like it but maybe y'all I don't know I
just my hunches you're probably not
waking up in the morning thinking like
maybe today's the day you know um so why
is that well that's some of it's the
cultural remoteness
um and some of is the kind of the the
falling down or the the leveling down
that these roles have had you know
there's but here's the question but why
the kind of leveling down why have they
kind of lost their cache you know lost
their oomph lost the of esteem and like
woo you know why don't they hold that
Mystique anymore uh and that brings me
to my main point which is um the abuses
of power I think that's a lot of what's
going on here I think that's why even
pastors are really hesitant to get up
and be like we're preaching on the
three-fold office tonight you know and
because these these terms you know it's
like the it just the way it it it just
doesn't sing you know and pastors are
really into things that sing for us to
put it poetic you know I mean like
things that I say the words and you're
like oh yeah you know pastors love that
and you say prophecy priesthood royalty
you know I don't know it's like there's
not as much um which is why I was
leaning on the Rowan Williams quote to
help you know kind of you and I even
heard a few like oh you know where
you're like okay maybe I get now why
you're saying these words you know um so
now what's happened right what do we
mean by abuses of power well think of it
like with the King right there's a
reason we don't have so many kings
around anymore more I me they're still
kind of there but now they're like kind
of a functionary like they don't
actually have power you know I mean it's
sort of like I'm thinking of like the
British Monarchy you know where it's
sort of like they got their other ways
the people the real politicians with the
power and then the you know the kind of
king and the Queen and kind of are
kingly and queenly but they don't like
you know they're more uh almost
ambassadors you know they can't like
make a law why because we realize like
that form of government it is right for
abuse uses of power you got people I
mean well you kind of cross your fingers
for like a good king or queen and then
that can be good but then what happens
when they're like brat child is you know
the next in line that's oh great now we
got a despit on our hand you know so we
figured out it was just too much abuse
of power and what was true there um has
kind of played out even in the the area
of the prophetic I um mention quite
often I came from a charismatic
Pentecostal background so I'm you know
familiar with the the role of of kind of
prophets and um all of the the beautiful
and the terrible of that happens there
now what's the terrible where what what
goes wrong well you can think of it like
in this way like prophecy is power right
to say especially on a Mike you know
this is the word of the lord it's like
who you know like okay this is what God
thinks of you you know what I mean like
that so so you can see where it's sort
of this powerful sword so to speak like
on the one hand it can be really
good um as we'll kind of get to later
but you can see we can also get terribly
sideways can can hurt um hurt people in
fact there's been some uh I won't name
names but like there's a place the
International House of Prayer in Kansas
City um a whole kind of movement there
and a place where the prophetic operates
and like the leader like have this whole
downfall
and like turns out using that power
right to do what it turns out there's
like like kind of spiritual abuse that
maybe then turned into kind of sexual
manipulation it's just a
mess right just a a mess and uh none of
you were probably shocked by this you
know you're not like what in the church
you know oh man I didn't expect that to
get quite a laugh you know sort of like
when you're it's like when your feelings
are like a little bit hurt like I make a
joke oh
yeah it's hilarious right you know says
the pastor but actually it's a good
transition because then we come to
pastors you know and what is true for
the king and the prophets I mean is
certainly I don't have to say it for the
the Priestly and the Pastoral Ro I'm not
just going to pick on Catholic Church
like it's Protestants too we all it's
just uh we're we're a hot mess you know
um we all know the scandals abounding
and and often it's the high-profile
names you know Bishop whatever you know
so and so or mega church pastor so and
so and that you know that's what makes
the headlines I think the real the the
pain is the way this plays out you know
in like widespread you know the it's the
little church like you know the table
you know like a thousand 10,000 little
churches scattered all over the world
and that's where what happens the the
pastor um ends up using the the mic and
the power to Center themselves and they
end up um hurting so many people in fact
some something you may not know um is uh
most pastors that I know actually I
would say all um kind of hide a little
bit the fact that they are pastors
here's what I mean like when I go out
into the world so to speak I just you
know outside of these walls and I meet
people I'll tell you friend I am in Zero
Rush to tell them that I am a
pastor um and hopefully you know why
right it's not because I'm you know a I
don't like being a pastor and so I don't
want to talk about no it's not that and
B it's not I hope and pray Lord the keep
on this you know where where I'm
secretly want to manipulate them or
something so I'm not going to tell you
no no it's what is it it's because of
their experiences you know what I mean
that it's just it's more likely that
they've had a negative experience than
that they've had a positive one I mean
maybe if it was like 99 times out 100
they like they're like what a pastor
give me a hug you know maybe then I'd be
like hey I'm a pastor you know I mean to
be actually wanting to venture that
information when they're like what do
you do um and this is why Pastor I mean
I know this is the classic line pastors
say uh like what do you do oh I work for
a nonprofit that's what they say they do
a lot of I work for a nonprofit I don't
do that I try not to do that although I
noticed even last night I was there uh
at 12 stories coffee for Jesse Watts if
anyone number of you made it out to hear
Jesse it's so good playing his music it
was freaking awesome um but I get there
and the the gentleman behind I guess I
found out later the kind of owner
operator of this coffee shop Marty he um
sees me I come in you know and I can
hear the music going but I need to you
know I want to order something I need I
want to order something and uh so I'm
ordering he's like oh so uh you here for
Jesse I was like yeah he's like oh how
do you know him and without even y'all
without even thinking about it I
subconsciously already started steering
the convers like I didn't say like oh
I'm the pastor at his church you know no
I said oh I I didn't even say Seminary
said oh I uh I went to school with
Jesse which just
true but he was on I guess he already
knew and he's like oh he goes I Know Who
You Are
you
know oh my
goodness yeah so you can see right point
being boy we're the these have taken a
hit in years prophecy priesthood royalty
taken a taken a hit taken a blow and you
might wonder then why man why do this
message on baptism this is supposed to
be a happy occasion you know um here's
why uh hiding in every crisis is an
opportunity church and in this time of
spiritual
impoverishment in an in a an era of
institutional decay in an Epoch of time
where no one heeds the voice of the
Prophet anymore or the words of the
priest or the pastor or the solemn
decrees of the king or the politician in
this cultural moment when
cynicism over leaders and religious
people of every type runs absolutely
rampant and as we've named pretty much
mostly for good
reason this is precisely when I believe
Christians need to pay attention not
only to the fact that Jesus fulfilled
these three roles but how he did it how
he fulfilled them because I don't think
the answer is so therefore those are
terms are a mess so let's reject them
let's run away from them you know
leadership who needs it you know like no
I I I think we've got to do is tune into
how he fulfilled the role you see at
their worst prophets priests leaders
become obsessed with their own
Egos and self
aggrandisement the prophet wants
attention the priest wants Center Stage
the leader wants power power power but
what does Jesus do Jesus models a
different way entirely Jesus models and
embodies the way of self-emptying love
where it's not about what you get from
people but what's it about it's about
what you give it's about giving it's not
about your own egoic needs oh I'm
insecure oh I need this oh I need
attention oh I need like no we've got to
move we got to start moving beyond that
and say you know
what I'm
okay Jesus loves me I'm okay how can I
be there for you how can I love you how
can I serve
you how can we be there for each
other like oh that's that's the
magic that's where the holy spirit is
now like on the move as people begin to
step into this threefold office because
you when you think of Jesus how did he
do this like he fulfilled the prophetic
role he did that but he did not he he
didn't speak
harshly to the poor and the downtrodden
and the marginalized and the abused he
spoke he reserved his tough words for
people like me honestly uh pastors
priests and such religious leaders
that's who he was like kind of could
give a tough word to to the masses like
to the just regular folks he was like a
little lamb you know what I mean like he
was so kind and and gentle right so he
could fulfill that that that role but it
was not words of judgment and
nullification it was encouragement it
was God's on your side you know and he
fulfilled the Pastoral the Priestly role
but he didn't do it by centering his own
needs and you know no he he centered
others and he fulfilled the the
leadership royalty role but he did it by
how I mean again think of the Cross like
that was Christ's kind of enthronement
ceremony
the
cross and then Resurrection Life like
that's a different kind of moment than
hey it's about me you know what I mean
like no no this is a a deep laying down
of your life like that's a servant
leadership that's what he did so
powerfully and so as the baptized ones
as Christians I believe it's time for us
to now reclaim these ways of being
because here's the truth even in a
secular age where people kind of you
know no long as I said no longer heed
the the voice of the pastor or the
politician the same way they once to
once did um even in this secular age boy
I think we still need these roles I
think we still long for people to step
into them from the prophets don't we
still need lifegiving words from God
don't we still need someone to look at
us and say the Lord is with you God is
on your side God loves you with an
everlasting love God sees
you God celebrates
you I mean who does it oh who doesn't
need that you know what I mean oh yes
like we need we need that we need
that and um in the same way from pastors
and uh and those are the pastoral heart
here I'm not just talking about myself
I'm I'm really I'm thinking of every
Meetup leader I'm thinking every time
someone feels kind of just a little
prompting of the spirit and they reach
out and they text or they call someone
hey just thinking about you you know
like I mean do we do we still need that
kind of heart do we still need the
Pastoral heart that's here for others of
course we do it's like the glue that
holds communities and fam and
friendships and churches like together
like we
absolutely need that that people who say
I will stand in the gap for you when you
feel like you cannot stand
anymore I'm going to be there for you
can you see though where that's
different than the kind of pastoral
Priestly role that says well it's about
me I've got a position you
know I'm the I'm I mean think it Place
could play out in this community you
know I'm a I'm a Ministry team leader
now or you know I am a Meetup leader you
know what that means you listen to me
you know you can see where this gets so
sideways so quickly and so un
Christlike because to to be the pastor
as Christ did oh it's like the opposite
of that right it's just a a laying down
of your life for the Beloved Community
and finally from the the royalty leader
role oh we need servant leadership don't
we I mean in churches in society I mean
we just desperately
need that kind of heart a heart again
that says it's just not about me but
it's about other people in the community
what what do you need to
thrive what do we need to
thrive um you know when I think of that
kind of role I was thinking through each
of these roles and kind of who steps
into this
um I was thinking in the prophetic role
there's a she hasn't been here um in a
while but Nikki Parker for those who
remember Nikki was a beautiful example
of that prophetic role like she would
just see things notice things and like
encourage people it was so beautiful
when I think of um the kind of pastoral
role I think of um Miranda and Ramone
Delgado leading their Wy Meetup like
they do it so beautifully I think of um
Raymond luster who's I think texts half
the church maybe like just connecting
how are you you I think he sex young
more than me you know I use that little
cheat where I use my little group me
thing and send out a group text you know
um he is like just that pastor's heart
you know when I think of servant
leadership I think of Mindy rynolds who
leads us in worship each week um who
this especially that kind of role it's
upfront you know it just it does lend
itself to kind of ego to start slipping
in there you know but Mindy just so
consistently makes it about other people
like it's about the team how they can
shine and it's about you all and what
you need um I think what I'm driving at
is like y'all oh let's keep stepping
into it you know let's don't reject
these
roles but let's be like Christ in in the
how focus on how he did them in closing
I want to read um this is from
Philippians 2 beginning in verse three I
think this is really at least in in my
opinion I think this is one of the
foundational texts in the New Testament
it's so powerful so I invite you to to
read along do nothing out of selfish
ambition or vain conceit rather in
humility value others above yourselves
not looking to your own interests but
each of you to the interests of the
others in your relationship with one
another have the same mindset as Christ
Jesus who being in very nature God did
not consider equality with God something
to be used to his own advantage AG
rather he made himself nothing Greek
word there is um eosin the root is kosis
which means
self-emptying see that's the call
self-emptying love not
self-centering but a self-emptying
Love by taking the very nature of a
servant and being made in human likeness
and being found in appearance as a man
he humbled himself self by becoming
obedient to death even death on a
cross so church I hope you can see boy
if you're here tonight and you are part
of the community of the baptized if
you're a follower of Jesus then you're
called to the three-fold office you're
called to
it but do it
beautifully do it
humbly do it the way Christ would do it
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so the moment you've all been waiting
for tonight uh we get some baptisms and
uh our Lord Jesus Christ has told us
that to um enter into the kingdom of
heaven we must be born again of water in
the spirit and he's given us baptism as
the sign and the seal of this new birth
here we are Washed by the Holy Spirit
and made clean here we are clothed with
Christ dying to sin that we may live his
risen life and now as children of God we
have a new dignity and God calls us to
fullness of
life so kiddos glad you could be with us
tonight we have two wonderful people um
being
baptized and uh first I'm gonna invite
up
Jennifer since Casey made it very clear
that she wanted Jennifer to go first
so all right my
friend come on over
here oh here switch
spots Jennifer
so can you go ahead and um share with
everyone why you'd like to be baptized
today just to kind of get some context
to the answer that question but um when
I was 10 or 11 um I did I got saved got
baptized um I was in a Baptist Church at
that time um continued to go to Baptist
Church till my like early 20s I think um
then um live some life in there but late
20s um I started going to another church
a non-denominational
charismatic Evangelical Church um I was
there for about 10 years um in that 10
years um well eight of them I served on
the worship team um I then was um
leadership in the church as a whole in
those last several years um I led um the
girls 13 to like 16-year-old youth class
um it's a lot of leadership in there um
um in there knowing somewhere deep down
I wasn't really being Who I Really Am um
but of course suppressing that um you
know because that's not right it's not
okay it's a sin you know whatever I've
been told and had been learning
um until like I couldn't hold that back
anymore um I knew that I wasn't truly
being who I felt I was supposed to be um
then I met Casey she's my wife and um
you know and then I was coming into that
and realizing like I needed to be me um
regardless of what that was going to
look like um not still not knowing
whether that was okay you know in my
faith in Christianity um I walked away
from the church because I knew where
they stood on it and I knew that it
wasn't going to be okay and I knew there
would be the meetings and the prayers
and let's pray it out of you and why do
you feel this way and um probably even
want W like I knew they were going to
want me to give some
biblical background on or standpoint on
why I was feeling this way but I didn't
have any at that time I just knew this
is who I who I was um Ste down um it was
very tough lost a lot of friends um
obviously lost my church family my
church Community um it was tough even
with my personal family um but this was
you know what I was wanting to do for me
so I went through of course the pain
hurt from that and then that
deconstruction um and multiple times
Casey's like let's find a church let's
go to church just went to church and I'm
like no I'm not ready for that because I
um didn't lose my faith in God still God
was number one to me um loved him
believed in him but I didn't trust the
church anymore um so it was really hard
to like why do we find a church and how
do I know they're going to be accepting
or I wanted more than just showing up on
a Sunday I wanted to be in involved I
wanted to I mean I'd already held
leadership places and and that was my
heart but how was I going to find that
again um and how was i g to find a
church that would allow me to do that
being you know gay so um I had to just
get through that um then finally Casey
had found the table online and she's
like I found an affirming Church like
let's go to church and I'm
like okay let's try it um she had me
look it up online so you know we started
coming and we've been coming almost a
year now um but all that to say that you
know my why being you know I I struggled
with it for a for a little while like
should I get baptized should I not
because I felt like that was kind of
resonating in me but I was like I've
been baptized already before you know um
I went to the class that he had for the
the the baptisms and um I still wasn't
100% sure yet until I heard him talk
about just some of those reasons how
your um baptism is with Christ and it's
with the church the community and with
all people and then that's just kind of
when it hit me like yes like let's do
this because well yes I have been
baptized with Christ um I felt as those
other things that maybe I hadn't really
done yet and especially here and so for
me it's um you know it's a reaffirming
and it's been completely different
Journey since I've come here and um so
just baptizing with y'all as my my
church my church family my community um
where I've um re rusted the church the
church um grew in My Hope and my faith
um and just overall um and then also
just being in a place where I know that
I'm loved for who I am and I'm affirmed
um whether I know you or whether you
know me I know that I'm loved and it's
just um really great to be in a place
like that and so that's why I'm doing
this today thank you thank you thank you
go ahead and
stand it should be pretty warm you want
to um face that way yeah there you
go
yeah yeah go all right Jennifer do you
repent of the sins that separate us from
God God and neighbor I do do you turn to
Christ as Savior I do do you submit to
Christ as Lord I
do gra there put your other hand and
grab right there there you go Jennifer
because you repent of the sins that
separate us from God and neighbor
because you turn to Christ as Savior and
submit to him as Lord I now baptize you
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy
Spirit
[Applause]
so happy for
you all right
Casey it's your turn
friend
okay see you go ahead and share with
everyone uh why you'd like to be
baptized
today yes so um I was Christan as a baby
in the United Methodist Church I was
sprinkled um baptism when I was 11 in
the United Methodist Church um bear with
me sorry I'm like super nervous public
speaking is not my strong point um and I
lived a lot lot of life since I was 11
um at 18 I decided I wasn't going to
live a lie and came out with being gay
um I knew the road that I was about to
go down wasn't going to be an easy one
um in fact I knew uh the church I had
grown up in um wasn't um completely open
and accepting um lost some relationships
there um but I never gave up on my faith
I knew the relationship I had with God
was super strong um and even though um
been told my whole life that if you're
gay you're going to hell um was
something strong that I was dealing with
I still never gave up and um
sorry
um through that I started going to
different churches um wasn't accepted um
I knew I wanted to be a leader in a
church so when I met Jennifer in 2020
that was kind of like a turning point
for me um I still stayed who I was um
between there I went through a 5-year
domestic violence relationship um almost
lost my life uh never give up Faith and
through that um I told Jennifer I was
like there's got to be a church out
there there's got to be a church out
there that we can find um we found the
table a year ago and that was like
turning point for us even walking
through those doors I remember meeting
you and I was like uh you know we we
went to this meeting of getting to know
the table and I was like just kind of
waiting for the the talk to come the you
know like the talk I've been hearing for
all these years now and it never
happened and so when I met Brett I was
like okay is this the day like is this
the day you're going to tell me that you
know we can't be here if we're gay and
he was like absolutely not um and from
that moment on I knew that this has been
what I've been praying for for all these
years to find a church um that I could
raise a family and and um just be that
have that faith that I've held on to all
these years um so that's why I want to
reaffirm my faith with my church
[Applause]
family he's getting a little
chilly if we didn't want to keep the
heaters in here that might be a hazard
so it just helps keep it real yeah all
right well Casey do you repent of the
sins that separate us from God and and
from neighbor yes do you turn to Christ
as Savior I do do you submit to Jesus
Christ as Lord I
do right there right there Then Casey
because you repent of the sins that
separate us from God and neighbor
because you've chosen to submit to
Christ as Savior and turn to him as Lord
I now baptize you in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit
[Applause]
oh beautiful beautiful you give them
another round of
[Applause]
applause and will you go ahead and uh
bow your heads close your eyes for for
me to
pray Lord
Jesus we pray that our new siblings in
Christ would flourish in every
way we pray that their
families their schools their places of
work their
communities would be blessed for their
commitment to love and serve you we pray
that they would become models of
christlikeness patient kind loving deep
Wells of compassion and moral courage
and we pray that all of us who have
witness this day would be renewed in our
own baptismal vows ready to embrace and
live out the three-fold office in the
Holy Name of Christ I pray
amen
youed
fear yourself lo you the voices inside
of your head you the shame and reproach
of your failure it's time to your
belov
you owned your and it's def you've owned
everything else says It's Time toar what
your father
spoken your mind smil when I made you I
find you
in my love for you isier and
uning I'll come to find you whatever it
takes my
belov
[Music]
youor you the lies that you're just not
enough you've been so blind
by all
comp he says you're mine smil when I
made I
youtiful in every
way my love for you is fierce and
unending I'll come to find you whatever
it takes
my
[Music]
belove you are
completely loved and fully
[Music]
know beloved
believe he died to me make your
[Music]
heart home and he says you're mine smil
I made you I You Beautiful
in love
you
[Music]
I'll he says you're smil when I made I
find you beautiful in every way my love
for you isce
anding I'll come to find you whatever
ites my
Bel
[Music]
thanks you guys thank you all for being
here tonight um what a beautiful service
um I am so grateful to Jennifer and
Casey and their courage and their
stories
um I I was touched by it I hope I hope
you were too um um and I hope it
reminded you that no matter where you're
at you're not alone and you're loved and
God will always be there for you um
don't forget the announcements from
earlier we have handouts they're on the
table as you go out the door to your
right there's like a blue tablecloth
over it the workshop that's happening
Thursday night as well as our new
location that starts Sunday February 4th
um also if you need prayer or somebody
to to talk with or just a hug feel free
to find me after the service I would
love to be there for you however I can
um also as we are stretching ourselves
in all the ways to move into a new
building and a new place um that is
stretching our finances a bit honestly
and we would love for you to partner
with us by making a financial donation
you can use the QR code up on the screen
or you can go to our website at the
table te tx.org that is another area of
worship it's a giving in faith and a
giving of love to allow this community
to grow and for stories like Jennifer's
and Casey's to just continue to Ripple
out um and make an impact uh in our
community that's I mean we want that
that's that's our heart uh for our
community and uh lastly uh oh also if
you are visiting with us tonight you can
use that QR code or grab a little card
on your way out on the same table as the
handouts please fill out one of those
cards with your name and contact
information drop it in the little box we
would love to be able to reach out to
you this week and just say thank you for
for visiting with us all right lastly uh
I would love to send you all out into
your week with a benediction which is
just a fancy word for a blessing for the
road as you go so if you're comfortable
doing so go ahead and stand to your
feet and some people like to hold their
hands out in a posture of receiving uh
you can close your
eyes um or you can just open your heart
to these words that I believe are true
for each and every one of you who are
here and also those of you who are
watching
online you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best
day and it's true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week
ahead with it's yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy and
you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of love and grace and compassion
to everyone you come in contact with be
blessed have a good night and we'll see
you back here next week good
night when I made you I find you
beautiful in every way my love for you
is fierce and an ending I'll come to
find you whatever it
Tes my
Bel it's time
[Music]
your